John you have said and I found this to
be curious that you prefer rude
questions from journalists Oh light ones
are you talking about
well if people say what is your favorite
sketch you drew really don't like dogs
it doesn't lead anywhere right somebody
says why we being married so many times
why don't you know you prefer someone to
say said what's your favorite color
you'd like them to say white even
married so many times yeah but it's more
interesting you know yeah you don't get
upset when someone asks you that no when
you couldn't upset me if you tried okay
why have you been married so many times
all right I'm off well how about this
he married for 34 years yes - for
different for different wife
is that what is your favorite is that
your favorite rude question is about
what's your favorite don't ask him he's
but I love you remarried to that
dreadful woman oh my gorgeous Chicago
wife yes almost 40 years 40 years I mean
40 years or so that's a lack of
imagination
[Laughter]
you need imagination to be with a woman
for 40 years and I gave that woman two
of the best years of my life what a
giant et my ex-wives died you know that
it was very sad because it was the wrong
one my god all right I hope that one's
watch yeah yeah do you have real anger
hatred towards your any of your ex-wives
no no no I mean I'm quite happy if one
or two of them were dead but I have
nothing
[Laughter]
dead in the nicest body and not slow
agonizing deaths that are drawn out of
American ears or anything like that no
something quick like a tree falling on a
rental car yeah how many okay even
married 40 years lovely woman I don't
met your wife what is the secret though
what is the secret I admit I used to say
the secret of marriage is having
separate bedrooms but now I think it's
having separate countries that's very
nice I think that the secret is not to
have children
really oh yeah children no children are
the cause of most of the misery in the
world they can't support you you worry
yourself sick and then they grow up like
their mothers you're not safe going
anywhere
so you upset I've actually heard you say
that you did prefer having children you
think people should have cats cats cats
cats are the answer lovely there they
you they're very affectionate yeah and
feed them twice a day and also they're
the only ones you can really [ __ ] grab
[Applause]
I've known in 1350 three years ago no
hope there's no hope all right we're
gonna take a break I'm gonna talk to
both of you and you're gonna behave when
we return later I'm gonna stick around
much more with John Cleese Eric Idle
[Applause]
you